tengo esta matriz de 2 x 2 y este vector
nr 2 llamado b y vamos a descubrir
algunas cosas interesantes que podemos
calcular de esta matriz y de este vector
así que lo primero de que que nos
interesa ver y que nos ayudará a
visualizar lo que vimos en el último
vídeo es ver quién es el espacio nulo
dea y el espacio nulo de a es
exactamente el mismo que el espacio nulo
de su forma reducida y escalonada por
renglón es verdad entonces vamos a
calcular esa es a esa forma de esta
matriz y y lo primero que podemos hacer
es tomar este primer renglón y
multiplicarlo por 2 x menos 2 aquí nos
quedaría menos 6 y aquí 4 si lo sumamos
al segundo renglón y es ahí donde vamos
a entrar nos quedaría menos 6 más 60 y 4
menos 4 es 0 entonces nuestra primera
parte nos queda 3 y menos 2 y aquí abajo
nos quedaría como 0 y 0 ok ahora
vamos a pasarlo a otra forma al
multiplicar el primer renglón por un
tercio y un tercio y nos queda tres por
un tercio es uno y menos dos por un
tercio es menos dos tercios y acá abajo
se queda igual ahora si queremos
encontrar el el espacio nulo de esta
matriz tenemos que ver todos aquellos
vectores x1 y x2 queremos ver que deben
cumplir para que al multiplicarlos por
esa matriz nos dé el vector cero
entonces con esto dicho vamos a hacer si
nos damos cuenta el segundo renglón no
nos da ninguna información verdad así
que solo nos quedaremos con la
multiplicación del primer renglón por
este vector y que es 1 por x 1 que es x1
menos dos tercios de x2 y esto me debe
dar igual a cero o lo que es lo mismo si
pasamos este término del otro lado nos
dice que x 1 es igual a dos tercios de x
2 y sólo para que veamos que realmente
no es que x 2 y x 1 sean algún número en
especial vamos a
parametrizar esto es decir vamos a
suponer que x2 es un número real te ok
digamos que es cualquier número real ok
y entonces x1 x1 sería dos tercios de t
perfecto solo para pensar que esto lo
hicimos para pensar que no es un número
especial ok entonces quién sería
finalmente el espacio nulo de nuestra
matriz el espacio nulo es el conjunto de
los x 1 x 2 que sean iguales a la
siguiente forma fíjense que x1 debe ser
dos tercios de t entonces y x2 este
entonces podemos factorizar la t y x1
debe ser dos tercios de t
x2 debe ser una t muy bien entonces este
es nuestro espacio nulo que también lo
puedo escribir de la siguiente forma
por ejemplo si nosotros hacemos t
igual a 3 c digo cualquier número es el
triple de otro verdad entonces esto
sería el conjunto de los x 1 x 2 que
sean iguales a hace
ok hace y el 3 hay que multiplicarlo
aquí dentro y 3 por dos tercios es 2 y 3
por 1 es 3 ok entonces si nos damos
cuenta
aquí estamos diciendo que el espacio
nulo es el espacio generado por el
vector dos tercios y en realidad este
cambio de variable que hice decir que te
es igual a 13 lo hice para que no
aparezcan fracciones y se vea más
agradable esta expresión entonces esto
no es otra cosa más que el espacio
vectorial generado por un vector que es
el vector 23 ok entonces este es el
espacio nulo de nuestra matriz y visto
lo que vimos en el vídeo anterior es que
si teníamos la ecuación a x igual a b
pues nos interesaba saber quién era el
es para el conjunto solución de esta de
esta ecuación verdad entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es calcularlo también
vamos a considerar la matriz
6 - 4 ok
dejen quitar esto y lo que vamos a hacer
es aumentar esta matriz vamos a
aumentarla y vamos a poner nuestro
vector b
y vamos a poner esto de esta forma ok
vamos ahora a encontrar quién es el
conjunto solución de esta matriz
entonces vamos a ir la reduciendo
también y lo que podemos hacer es
exactamente lo mismo multiplicar x
por menos dos el primer renglón y
sumarlo al segundo entonces 3 x menos 12
6 6 es 0 déjenme déjenme poner déjenme
ir escribiendo esto porque el primer
renglón queda igual
y ahora vamos viendo vamos viendo 3 x
menos 2 es menos 660 menos 2 x menos dos
es cuatro menos cuatro nos da cero y
nueve por menos dos es menos 18 18 nos
queda 0 entonces ya nada más para
terminar esta expresión está en esta
forma vamos a multiplicar el primer
renglón por un tercio y entonces nos
queda x 0 0
eso se quedan iguales y aquí nos queda
uno menos dos tercios y nueve entre 3 es
3 muy bien ok entonces qué es lo que es
lo que tenemos aquí lo que vamos a tener
es que podemos expresar lo también en
forma matricial es decir como una
especie de una matriz por un vector por
ejemplo esto lo que nos está diciendo es
que uno menos dos tercios esta matriz 00
que multiplica al vector x 1 x 2 es
igual al vector 3 0 verdad esto ya lo
hemos visto en varios vídeos anteriores
y esto inmediatamente nos da una
ecuación nuevamente el segundo renglón
no nos da información quien nos da
información es el primero porque porque
tenemos que 1 x x 1 es x 1
y menos dos tercios por x2 es menos dos
tercios de x2 y esto debe ser igual a
tres o lo que es lo mismo si despejamos
x1 este pasa sumando del otro lado y x1
es tres más dos tercios de x2 muy bien
nuevamente vamos a usar el mismo el
mismo truco que usamos anteriormente
digamos que x2 es cualquier número real
y entonces x1 es igual a tres más dos
tercios
dt y estamos parametrizado esto entonces
este conjunto solución de la ecuación
simplemente nos queda el conjunto de los
x 1 x 2 tales que debe ser igual
bueno es x 1 debe ser 3
algo porte que es dos tercios verdad y
x2 este entonces aquí va un cero y aquí
va un
muy bien entonces ya con esto podemos ir
observando algo esto es una solución
particular de nuestra ecuación verdad si
uno pone 30 como x nos podemos dar
cuenta que es un que es una solución
particular y esto es el espacio en el
espacio generado por él por el espacio
nulo es decir déjenme irlo escribiendo
de esta forma por ejemplo si nuevamente
lo escribimos como 13 esto simplemente
va a ser el conjunto de los x 1 x 2 que
sean iguales a 30 más
y aquí el 3 lo multiplicamos por el
vector que es 23 verdad ok y esto es
exactamente la forma que teníamos acá
arriba verdad el espacio nulo era
generado por el 23 que aquí lo tenemos y
desplazado después por una solución
particular que es el 3 el 30 ok entonces
vamos ahora nada más saber quién es
nuestro espacio fila ya para ir
concluyendo todo esto porque nuestro
espacio fila lo podemos calcular de la
siguiente forma que es el espacio
columna de la matriz a transpuesta este
es el espacio fila
fila y esto será igual al espacio
vectorial generado pues por las filas
verdad por las filas de la matriz que es
3 - 2
aunque el primero es 3 menos 2 y también
por el generado y también generado por 6
y menos 4 pero si nos damos cuenta este
definitivamente es el doble de este
anterior entonces este realmente no
pinta y solo nos queda que es el espacio
vectorial generado por el vector
3 - 2 este es el espacio fila y que
sabemos que es ortogonal el espacio fila
es ortogonal al espacio nulo al espacio
no lo de la matriz entonces en el último
vídeo tuvimos un resultado muy
importante y que vamos a tratar de ver
gráficamente vamos a tratar de hacerlo
esto muy gráfico
vamos a hacer vamos a hacer los ejes
espero me salgan
derecho
y está bien
efe
vamos a ponerle la dirección en ambos
sentidos y ahora aquí tenemos el otro en
el eje x de nuestro espacio r 2 muy bien
ahí tenemos eso y ahora vamos a ir
graficando poco a poco estos espacios
que ya tengo primero vamos a graficar el
espacio nulo que el espacio nulo es el
generado por el vector 23
vamos a tomar dos en esta dirección y
luego tres hacia arriba
y entonces este es el vector 23 pero
como es el generado en realidad estamos
hablando de toda esta línea de toda esta
línea toda la línea
este es el espacio vectorial generado
por el 23 ok entonces este es
espacio nulo de la matriz muy bien ahora
vamos a graficar el espacio el conjunto
de las soluciones porque el conjunto de
las soluciones aquí está aquí abajo es
el espacio nulo pero desplazado un 30 es
decir si aquí tenemos el 30 aquí está el
12 30 ahora a este vector le voy sumando
todo el espacio nulo entonces
esencialmente lo que tengo es una recta
paralela a este espacio pero que pase
por el 30
aquí está el conjunto solución entonces
este es este es la luz el conjunto
solución
un poquito más abajo solución a x igual
a b ok
ese es el conjunto solución y finalmente
hay que graficar el espacio fila el
espacio fila que el espacio fila es el
generado por el 3 menos 2
entonces y aquí tenemos -1 y -2 por aquí
andará el 1 el vector que genera al
espacio fila y vamos a ponerlo con este
otro color
si puedes salirme más o menos derecho ok
ahí está nuestro vector y ahora vamos a
seguir generando todo este espacio que
es
una fila de vectores creo que me quedo
un poco chueco vamos a ver si podemos
hacerlo mejor
es un poco
para que nos
más o menos más o menos este es el
espacio el espacio fila como está
generado por este vector que es el 3
menos 2
ok y aquí hay algo que observar porque
aquí se ve exactamente como estos dos
espacios son ortogonales el espacio fila
este es el espacio fila que es el
espacio columna de la matriz transpuesta
y el espacio nulo de nuestra matriz
aquí se ve exactamente como son
ortogonales y ahora bien en el último
vídeo dijimos que tuvimos un resultado
muy interesante que teníamos que si
teníamos un vector b en el espacio
columna de nuestra matriz entonces la
solución más corta
vamos a hablar estamos hablando de la
solución la solución
la solución más corta
corta
a la ecuación a x igual a b es un
elemento es un elemento de habíamos
dicho del espacio fila es un elemento de
el espacio fila de nuestra matriz ok
entonces este es el resultado que
obtuvimos en el vídeo anterior en el
vídeo anterior y vamos a ver cómo lo
podemos representar en este en este
lugar porque fíjense aquí tenemos
nuestro espacio de soluciones y aquí
tenemos un punto y este punto de aquí
que de hecho voy a llamarle a este ere
r y ese punto es el único que se
encuentra tanto en el espacio fila como
en el espacio de solución es verdad esto
coincide con lo que habíamos visto en el
vídeo anterior solo hay un punto que
está tanto en el espacio fila como en el
espacio de la luz perdón como en el
conjunto de las soluciones de x igual a
b ahora la pregunta que tenemos es cómo
se detectó exactamente es este entonces
cómo sabemos que está en el espacio fila
como sabemos que está en el espacio fila
y el espacio fila está generado por el 3
- 2 entonces podemos garantizar que
nuestro vector r es una constante por el
vector
3 - 2 eso sí es cierto aquí aquí voy a
marcar bien quién es el vector
r
tengo
y también sabemos que este vector es el
vector 30 aquí tenemos el vector 30 este
es el 30 entonces sí nos damos cuenta
este vector que es la diferencia es
ortogonal al vector r verdad aquí se
hace un ángulo de 90 grados y eso hay
que verlo porque el espacio nulo es
ortogonal al al espacio fila y este
simplemente está desplazado entonces el
ángulo que forman y eso es porque son
también paralelas el ángulo que forman
es de 90 grados entonces este vector que
es la diferencia de ellos es ortogonal a
nuestro vector r entonces quién es la
diferencia quién es la diferencia tengo
mi vector r o más bien tengo mi vector
el 30 el 30 y si yo le restó el vector r
esto es el vector c por 3 - 2
esto es ortogonal al vector
3 - 2 verdad que es el que genera a
nuestro espacio a nuestro espacio fila
entonces si yo hago el producto punto
con el 3 - 2 ponerlo con este color con
el 3 - 2
esto me debe dar 0 esto debe ser 0 y con
esto podríamos calcular quienes la hacen
necesaria para saber cuál es el vector
que cumple esta propiedad que
encontramos en el vídeo anterior
entonces tenemos aquí este vector
amarillo de gm bueno lo va a poner en en
color blanco como está aquí en el dibujo
y entonces tenemos 3 - 13 verdades 3
menos 13 y acá abajo es 0 - c x menos 2
entonces
es este vector vamos a hacer el producto
punto con este otro vector que es el 3
menos 2 y eso nos debe dar igual a 0
entonces que cuál es la ecuación que hay
que resolver tenemos 3 menos 13 que sí
muy lo multiplicamos primero por 3 ahí
está este por este y ahora es más 12 por
menos 2 y esto debe ser igual a 0 y si
empezamos a desarrollar aquí tenemos 93
x 39 menos 13 por 3 es menos 9 c y ahora
12 x menos 2 es menos 4 c y esto debe
ser igual a 0 ahora tengo 9 c y 4 c
entonces esto es menos 3 cc y esto es 9
menos 13 c y esto es igual a 0 y de esto
finalmente podemos concluir que si
pasamos esto del lado derecho tenemos
que no
es igual a 13 c o bien que se es igual a
9 treceavos ok 9 sobre 13 y este es la
constante que me dice por cuánto hay que
estirar el vector tres menos dos que es
este este que estaba hasta acá ok
hay que estirarlo o más bien encoger los
913 a vos para encontrar la solución
agradable que habíamos visto en el vídeo
anterior es decir aquí podemos concluir
que nuestro vector r que era la solución
en el espacio fila es igual a 9 sobre 13
por el vector
3 - 23 menos 2 o lo que es lo mismo si
metemos este 9 13 años en el vector
3 x 9 27 sobre 13 y abajo será menos 2
por 9 menos 18 sobre 13 esta es mi
solución única y este de aquí es nuestro
vector más pequeño que satisface la
ecuación o mejor dicho es el único
elemento del espacio fila que es
solución de ax igual a b de esta de esta
ecuación donde aclaró aquí está de ax
igual a de i
es la única solución de x igual a b y
que coincide que la solución más corta
así este fue un ejemplo de lo que
hablamos en el último vídeo y espero que
haya que al menos hayas visto
visualmente por qué ocurre todo esto